what are your best tips for boosting
confidence
confidence is this thing
that you have to maintain
in in a business that is designed to
undermine your confidence at alter at
every turn
um I think I just was actually talking
to somebody yesterday who's having
um
a crisis is too strong a word but she's
at a Crossroads about something and
I said you know
here's your pro here's the problem we're
talking about
I said I think you need to do something
about that problem The Dilemma every day
do something every day even if it's 20
minutes even if you feel like you're not
making progress you're repeating
yourself you're digging yourself a hole
do something to get at that issue every
day because confidence is so fragile
there are people who are confident for
no apparent reason you know there are
they just have it
and they can't be dissuaded and God
that's a gift that's a fantastic gift
most of us who are mere mortals are not
like that
and so uh you know back in the day when
we used to go in for in-person auditions
which I don't know if that's ever coming
back
but you you know you'd arrive at the
audition
you pull up to the gate of the studio
and you'd say I'm gonna meet so and so
in this building and here's my
appointment they say oh you're not on
the list
okay so they got to call the office so
that's confidence number one going down
the tubes I'm not on the list then you
get on the list oh yeah yeah they've got
you so you got to park in that structure
it's like four blocks away so you got to
go park in that structure and you're
wearing a suit because it's a it's a
role that requires that and it's like
100 degrees out and you got to walk the
four blocks in the blazing sun and then
you get there and by the time you get
there you're a mess it's so it is
designed it's like a Minefield to
undermine your confidence and so
um
I'll tell you the best story that ever
happened to me and it has to do with
this issue
I was
um
I was getting I was getting out of the
shower one morning I got a call from my
agent
and they said can you be in Century City
at 10 o'clock and it was uh or whenever
it was it was I literally just stepped
out of the shower and it wasn't I live
in the valley I live in Studio City it's
rush hour in the morning
I said he said it's a movie somebody
must have fallen out you're next on the
list I don't even know what it is just
go there'll be sides for you there to
look at
so I'm like ready I'm getting in the car
and I'm trying to get through traffic
and park and and and talk about coffee I
don't know what's going on right
so I get there I see my sides I look at
them I read through it once and the
casting judges Michael are you ready
I want sure
I just said yes I think that's a big
part of confidence I just said yes I'm
ready I wasn't ready I wasn't even
remotely ready
but I said yes so I went into this room
and again another big room I didn't know
anything about this project
first person I see is Robert Duvall oh
wow yeah so I was like okay this is what
what is this I don't even know what this
is I have this long scene
and in those days they didn't expect you
to be off book you could still have the
script with you now everyone has to be
you know off book letter perfect and all
that stuff but I had the script and I
literally had just gotten it so I get
through to the I get to the end
it's very quiet in the room and the
director his name was Billy Graham by
the way oh William Graham a fantastic
guy
he looked at me said
that was perfect
I said really
I said that's not a word we hear too
often in rooms like this he said no that
was perfect
great I said well okay thanks guys and I
left and thinking what the heck just
happened
I didn't have time to have my confidence
shaken I just had to get it done I said
yes and I did it and the instincts we
talked about earlier just kicked in I
had a take on it oh but the other thing
was it was an Israeli character so I had
to have an accent
happened to be that my kids at the time
when they were young had an Israeli
Nanny and so I was very familiar with
you and I'm good with accents I was very
familiar with it
so I did it and they called back I don't
know a week or so later they want to
have you back a call back
and I'm thinking oh man
if I go back I'm going to probably blow
it
so no I'm not going to go back I I was a
crazy decision I said to my agent make
up something lie say I'm working I'm
available for the job but not for the
Callback
I don't know what possessed me
and uh I got it it was a job it was a it
was a Showtime movie with Robert Duvall
we shot in South America an incredible
project movie wasn't that great but it
was a great experience and working with
him was a great experience but it was
that level of
not
knowing enough to be scared
to be frightened to let it get in your
head we all get in our heads actors get
it but people do human beings do it's
it's it's so actors will get in their
heads about something and we feel we
have to be perfect we have to be I'm
working with somebody now who's who's
kind of new at this but she's really
extraordinary and
I've had to sort of cure her of being a
perfectionist I said I'm not I'm not
interested if you missed that one where
it doesn't matter if the take is great
if you like it if we like it that's what
we're going to go with and so once you
free yourself of
perfectionism
uh I think that let's opens the door for
a little bit more confidence when I work
with I've worked with a lot of people
who are dancers and athletes in
particular who are fantastically good
for acting because they are disciplined
they know they have to have training
they know they have to know what they're
doing they can't just wing it
and just oh I'm feeling it this way they
have to they actually know that they
need coaching and all that stuff and so
but they are perfectionists
dancers and athletes are perfectionists
when they transition into acting and so
it's a ques it's just getting them
confident enough to know that they can
be imperfect
and it's cool
you know sometimes when an actor drops
the line
like right now
you go oh what just happened that's
interesting you know sometimes when you
think oh What's My Line what's my name
what's my next line but you've had a
pause
it lets us in we go oh what's going on
that's cool but so it's
I do think confidence is directly
related to a sense of perfectionism and
if you have to be perfect your
confidence is going to be undermined at
all times if you accept the fact that
imperfection as long as it shows
Fidelity to the story to the script into
your character is fine it's much easier
and it's kind of what we're after anyway
I think
we talked about Tom Cruise earlier and
sort of this this composite of someone
that has unshakable confidence and is
going to get the job done but then you
think about a character like a Paul
Giamatti or Ileana Douglas who they they
show in facial expressions micro you
know like a little bit of doubt and then
we like them even more of course yeah
because they're like oh I see me in that
character exactly yeah I mean Paul
Giamatti is a great example because
he's just got that face he's got that
face that is only and the voice and he's
very good he's very very good but as I
said earlier I do think that faces and
worlds
I was telling the young woman yesterday
who I'm working with
who's got some confidence issues I said
you know if you think about it that way
like what world do you fit in you don't
fit in every world
I don't fit in every world what world do
you fit in
and I didn't get you didn't get that
role because
there's a lot of reasons you don't get
it wrong you maybe you didn't do a good
audition maybe your agent isn't
significant enough to really fight for
you maybe uh
you're too old for that character
because he or she has to be matched to
another person who's a little too young
a little young there's all kinds of
reasons and most of them are Optical
most of them are like how you look
and and so again we get back to that
blink of an eye thing so particularly
with self tapes now
I say you know you've gotta you have to
somehow
be there present and right at the first
frame absolutely the first 10 seconds
are the most important I had a a woman
who is a um
I won't name her she's but she's a very
significant casting person head of
casting at a network who came to my
class she was great she was
and somebody asked and so like if
there's a lead role in a in a television
series I don't know how many people are
submitted it's thousands probably and
then they get down they window it went
down and then maybe she sees the last 50
that have gotten through the Callback
process maybe it's even a smaller number
than that I don't know and somebody
asked how do you
uh like what's the process after that
and she literally took out her phone she
went
and everybody gasped because at that
point
she knows everybody's good
who's the right fit who looks right
it's kind of that I just cast this pilot
that I produced and it was like we had
people because we had a very good
casting director so we didn't see people
who weren't good we all everybody we saw
it for the major parts was very good so
it wasn't about that it was about like
oh she's great
doesn't fit it doesn't work for this
reason or that reason so it's a lot of
that it's a lot of that and and and
that sort of uncertainty and that
capriciousness
that's very capricious
as a profession and it's kind of
borderline abusive as some profession to
be perfectly honest particularly now
when an actor gets a a 12-page three
scene self tape with 24 hours to turn
around and he or she has a work shift
that night and they have to memorize it
and they have to film it and they have
to upload it and it has to be great come
on that's crazy
it's crazy but it is what that's the new
normal that is actually the normal now
they're trying to uh they've changed
that a little bit in the UK and I think
it's smart
they've given people they they send all
these these tapes out that are
it's impossible to do what they're
asking for some people
you know 12 13 pages when a show itself
is 60 pages
you're asking people to film a quarter
of the show that overnight and it has to
be great
in in the UK they're doing a thing they
uh four page maximum
with a four day minimum
and then if it's a six then it's a six
page they have a whole formula so it's
not otherwise it just gets to be crazy
and it's a good point you set a work
shift most actors have flexible jobs
that they're doing at night and things
yeah and so yeah you can't be totally
it's become that aspect of it has become
harder because it's not personal anymore
you're not walking into the room and
developing a maybe a relationship with
that office that you've been in six
seven times they like you they keep
bringing you back
there's an energy in the room there's a
person-to-person energy
that simply can't be replicated on Zoom
but that's what it is right now that's
that's the world we're living in and it
is what it is
I'm glad to be on the 17th hole
with that